apologize
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
horror movies just don't work when
you've got a Walter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I know
[Music]
[Music]
hmm bear with me today guess who's back
I have never uh you know it's funny it's
just low grade I don't know but since
I've had twins I've never been sick so
many times it's true and I know exactly
when it happened my son I was climbing
hold him up like this and the drool it
was like it happened in slow motion went
down and in my mouth like the embalming
fluid and dragged me to hell yeah and I
was like oh I'm gonna have a cold I
think I need to adjust my chair it's
still at Dave's setting yes it is yeah
and I need just my headphones glad to be
with you what are you saying boy
oh no the cat's out of the bag no and
everybody's gonna know I'm short oh
that's true how dare you well if they
find out I'm overweight I'm gonna have
to kill myself
he's from the Weight Watchers pygmy
truck
it's true uh no uh we have a lot to get
to fetterman of course debated yesterday
are you okay Joe yeah I see you screwing
around it takes a minute yeah my
headphones are different everything is
changing when we switch seats I moved
your chair down a little bit and you're
like what the hell this is a tad louder
yeah okay it is no I don't
think we're gonna talk about fetterman
and uh versus Dr Oz and now of course
everyone's talking about ableism that's
the only reason you might not like uh
you know a guy who looks like American
History X warmed over uh who can't
pronounce his own it's because you're
ableist and my question to you is do you
buy it is anyone buying this anyone
buying the ableism stuff nope ableism is
the new racism it's another way of
shutting down dialogue before you can
actually discuss ideas
and it's based on an identity it's shut
down dialogue based on identity so we
don't get two ideas so we'll be talking
about that also Taylor Swift uh can't do
anything right
good try to appease the lgbtqaip and
then uh you know ticked off the
fat Pride Community yeah they'll do it
no good deed goes unpunished all right
so we have that and more we're going to
be talking tell me I really want to talk
about today we've had this uh kind of in
the wings for a while uh the performance
of students in this country and I don't
know if you know it's the worst that
it's been as far as proficiency scores
since 1991. geez and now we have a
really clear contrast between Public
Schools run by the true heroes and
homeschooling
take a guess which one's doing better
Gerald a how are you sir I am so much
better now that my chairs adjusted
Justin I'm back in my zone yeah yeah
it's very limited it's a very Niche Zone
well and I know sound joke doesn't work
twice idiot
like I said that's why Gallagher brings
one watermelon listen like I said two
it's too much too much of a good thing
they end up like lizzo bad guys are my
zone what do you think I was talking
about
yeah just let him he's vibing he's right
in there
all right so uh of course you know him
you love him fastest man on his feet
he's actually going to be uh at the
Tampa Improv November 4th through fifth
uh yeah do I have that right November
fourth and fifth not fourth through
fifth it's two days you can go uh you
can go uh go watch him there uh Dave
Linda how are you Ahoy good you I'm fine
you know it's just it's it's staying
right here in my in my throat and in my
my nose so I'll be fine but it's just it
sounds worse than it is it's yeah you
sound better than yesterday a little bit
yeah it's just you know this is what
happens when you have little ones
they're just they're walking petri
dishes no I had just one and it was
constant so if you have one that's just
going to the other that's just going
back to you right just a triangle of
sick that's exactly what it is what do
they do before modern medicine they had
like 19 kids I'm surprised they weren't
all dead from SARS well they mostly were
yeah that's why you had 19 yeah some
would survive yeah that's actually true
yeah we're gonna lose at least a third
yes we don't know which ones of you are
gonna survive oh we did you forgot to
take into account the amounts who will
get kicked by horses oh sorry that's
gonna be three-fifths they're gone yeah
oh we better I have 20 and ruin your
body yes
and don't worry I'll take another wife
later on and she'll be really hot
imagine who discovered the C-section
poor broad okay oh geez so before we get
to any of that
apparently healthy
I discovered it on her
what is this I don't know we're rolling
the dice this could be great for us I'm
gonna cut right about there
you passed out when you're saying push
so we just did this yeah
good with it yeah she starts screaming
and pain like I better get the leeches
to suck the demons out of her
that's all you do is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
so apparently being uh healthy now and
having I I was told not to watch this
before it aired and I don't like that
but that's never a good thing apparently
being healthy and having a flat stomach
um is not considered attractive anymore
by the way that was societal
conditioning you like women who are
healthy no no this is what you want
this is just a reminder that your tummy
is so cute
so cute
screw you Gary he pulled that clip and
told me not to watch it he knew exactly
what was going to happen I ate oatmeal
this morning well did it look like that
yes
exactly like that that's the point I'm
such a hotter lady
play that again
they're trying to be cute with this
you're gonna
look at it
this is just a reminder that your tummy
is so cute so cute where's its arms
telling Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah
foreign
okay Mojo
that is disgusting well that's not even
like I don't understand how that
happened because the rest of the one
guess well
[Music]
stab at it fell out of it take a lipo
hello a tractor
um
can I just clarify one thing though too
look you have never ever on the show
heard me just go haha fat person ever
okay it's when people demand that you
praise them as beautiful and brave that
I have a problem with it when I see when
I see overweight people at the gym you
know it almost runs a tear to my they're
in there they're trying to make it
happen I go out of my way to encourage
them and say hey man you know we're all
we're all a work in progress hey I saw
you here last week that's more I make
sure to try and encourage them because I
know how hard it is on the flip side
also if I say a really fit person
jogging you ever do this while you're
driving and someone's jogging and they
look around they don't think anyone sees
them and they quit and they start
walking yeah I roll down the window and
go yeah
whenever I see a very attractive person
jogging I roll down the window and I'm
like Hey fat ass yes
it's not working it's homeostasis yes
you don't get to declare yourself
beautiful that's the thing it's not
something that you get to declare
remember when we used to say don't be
boastful wasn't there a fable about that
somewhere Aesop what's his name I
believe fables now it's just boast about
all the worst things that's the issue
here and by the way the reason that I
want to see people when I see them in
the gym when I see them bettering
themselves is because I don't want
people to no no no let me put it this
way
let's put a finer point on it remember
your stomach is cute you're dying
on camera yes that's what's happening
yeah you're dying that is unhealthy uh
you can be obese and be healthy no you
can't no you cannot it's just as healthy
no it's not only if you change the
definition of healthy yes exactly then
maybe yes
we're all dying a little bit you know
after a second of every day as soon as
you're born she's just dying a lot
faster a lot faster yeah yes the
half-life is different yeah also the
half leg which she's in she's in she's
sugar I'm just surprised it was so
hidden
[Laughter]
and then the edit like it's fat that
found out that there was no place to go
south and so they just started going out
well you think the fat just gives up
they're like I don't care how many
vertical stripes you wear this is
happening I got a belly and I just want
to know where to get those pants I I
don't know I'd like to feel more
comfortable yeah just shop at the
maternity store that's where I'll go
well you mean you mean continue to
that's probably where they're shopping
now didn't you didn't you kind of pick
up the hint when you were not pregnant
and you had to shop at the third
trimester section of the maternity store
that's because of the Miracle of Life
not Funyuns a shepherd husky boys
it's a 33-28 friend yeah
what never mind all right
gonna like the way you look in your
coffin yes they're gonna like the way
you look
the 19 year old bears are gonna like the
way
and hate the way you wait oh my gosh all
right okay
there's some kind of a Halloween joke in
there by the way we're doing our
Spooktacular on Monday costume contest
that we will have uh oh there you go
look you've got that right there okay
all right let's go to this and I
apologize I do have a lozenges in my
throat so can you guys hear that it's
just my own head I think it's just you
okay good I can't really hear it
otherwise it sounds gross okay so last
night we did this whole segment
yesterday Joe did a very good job the
the not only the debates but the actual
sort of state of our uh elections here
in the midterms last night was a big one
because you have two pricks
[Laughter]
you have doctors it's like Fair yeah and
then the third party it's like a booster
two Pricks and a booster
so you've got Dr Oz uh and I get it you
have to vote of the lesser of two evils
at this point I don't know how this guy
and well I do know how and unfortunately
I'm sad about it but not sad about it I
don't know like I don't have a dog in
this fight I don't like him what no you
should
fetterman either one of them but I would
vote for Oz if I had to right yeah but
people in Pennsylvania comment below how
do you feel having to pull the lever for
someone like like Dr Oz
has there has there been a more
clear-cut example of someone who isn't
really a constitutional conservative but
has an R next to their name and I get it
you're voting for the platform at this
point believe me I'm certainly not
saying you shouldn't go out and vote but
that's a pretty rough choice so last
night Dr Oz and fetterman debated um and
he's what you want to call it yes and
fetterman just said fire bad
pretty much you didn't have to pull the
fire alarm either yeah well that was his
plan B
so fetterman was as you would expect and
people have talked about this is stroke
we'll get into that more um a complete
and I mean he was worse than that he was
worse than that poor stomach lady he was
a complete mess
as lieutenant governor you're running
for a seat that could decide the balance
of power in Washington what qualifies
you to be a U.S senator you have 60
Seconds
hi good night everybody
seriously Mr Oz I do want to clarify
something you're saying tonight that you
support fracking that you've always
supported fracking but there is that
2018 interview that you said quote other
times so how do you square the two
foreign
fracking and there's a question I don't
I don't there was one I support fracking
and I stand and I do support fracking
spend because you have 60 Seconds
till what
no here's what tomorrow you have to
fight about inflation here right now
that's what we need to fight about
inflation you know right now because
it's a tax on Working Families
now we we all have to make sure that
everyone that works is able to that's
that's the most American bargain that if
you work full-time you should be able to
live in dignity as well true and I
believe they haven't have any businesses
being being uh you can't have businesses
being subsidized by not paying
individuals that just simply can't to
pay their own way
we are all now stupider
look look I get that you're going to
think this is rude
what do you even say to that what do you
look people that right now this is
trending everywhere we'll get to it it's
able lists to say that this guy is not
qualified I don't know why there's a
trend you know you put up someone like a
like a former Vice President Joe Biden
and now you have this man now I don't
know I'm not an expert I will be clear
could be just a processing issue where
he's not speaking properly with Strokes
sometimes your brain works fine and your
mouth just can't it just can't connect
with the brain right so I don't know
but I do know that that was bad
well the answer itself if you made you
know if you combined everything really
didn't make any sense no so it would be
difficult to note his stance I don't
know if Elsa was the stroke talking or
like he was trying to Jedi mind trick
good night everybody yes yes I won
let's do it like
okay I also said I stand yes well that's
good yes when you're doing debate prep
because you know I make poop
I'm voting for it yeah yes just for
entertainment value for sure bait prep
here like doesn't your team go
oh crap like we we have a problem we
need to cancel this debate you should
have canceled the debate yeah like it
should never have happened if you were
going to be in that kind of shape to
perform because like you said maybe his
brain is working fine but I if I was a
voter right now who was potentially
going to vote for him maybe an
independent I would say write out your
answers for me yeah live show your
personal help and let me see that the
brain is actually still functioning and
it's just a speech processing issue
which if that's the case fine but what
are we going to do tomorrow night Dr Oz
same thing we do every night pinky try
to ruin the country lose an election
did I hit anything here toolman I hit a
button oh am I good all right thank you
okay so the the public was very clear as
to who won the debate this almost never
happens 82 believe that Dr Oz won the
debate and uh 18 18. yeah by the way
there's a plus or minus a margin of
error of 18. yeah seriously just trying
to screw with the polling average they
also pulled blow up Frankensteins that
were in people's front yards yes exactly
exactly they used car lot
how do you think how do you think
fetterman performed yeah two hands up if
Federman won okay got it all right good
good thank you all the News That's fit
to print here at quinnipediac all right
so uh here's how one Pennsylvania voter
put it uh themselves
so I was definitely I'm an independent
by the way I was definitely leaning
towards fetterman and I think I have
totally changed to the Oz side why I
felt that um fetterman I felt that
fetterman just looked like he didn't
have command of the facts I do think his
condition unfortunately is going to
affect his ability to do the job I
thought Oz uh was pretty clear on the
issues and I thought he presented
himself well and uh definitely threw out
some plans where I didn't see any plans
coming out of fetterman well Chris Chris
Cuomo's still alive he is I can't
believe he has a show it's not a sense
of the word yeah that's true I wonder
who he molest there yeah that was uh so
it's pretty cool by the way hit the like
button if you're okay with us uh we're
going to venture into ableist territory
here so just for those of you who don't
know fetterman did suffer a stroke and
of course horrible and I hope that he
recovers absolutely um May I believe it
was about and he disclosed it about uh
he disclosed it before the primaries
just to be clear just a couple of days
just a couple of days before the primary
but he said that uh he was given a clean
bill of health from his doctor and it
says the good news is I'm feeling much
better the doctors told me I didn't
suffer any cognitive damage and the
doctor in a letter Dr Clifford Chen said
he has no work restrictions and can work
fully do full Duty in public office
which is good for him because I don't
know like he's more he's more capable
than Lena Dunham
Dr Chen is also Dr Oz's assistant yes
yes he's like oh yeah you're good to go
yes exactly was Dr Chen watching last
night yes would you like to revise his
testimony and I don't think it's ableist
if you're worried about you know the
Neurology of uh
yes because being able to date yeah
being able to communicate your point is
necessary in the Senate when you're
debating other Senators when you're
trying to get a bill going when you're
trying to speak to your constituents or
the American people like being able to
communicate your point we've seen this
with Joe Biden yeah we've made fun of it
it's like everybody says nothing wrong
here it's just a stuttering problem and
now you're going after him for
Saturday's like no other people are
looking at this other other world
leaders are looking at Joe Biden now
maybe other world leaders won't look at
fetterman but definitely other states
you mispronounced laughing yes I was
being nice yes yes yes you were they're
looking at this and seeing somebody who
doesn't seem to be all there well even
if maybe they are I think the
differences is Federman admitted he had
a stroke yes he did and Biden doesn't
admit that he has one every 15 minutes
right well they're called mini strokes
they're absent seizures yes that's true
but I'm not a doctor I'm just guessing
uh here's the thing also again I've had
people in my family who've had strokes
and I've also had people in my family
who've suffered from you know cognitive
decline
um six months is a pretty it's a pretty
important Benchmark for stroke victims
that's when you'll have a pretty clear
idea if they're going to recover or to
what degree they're going to recover
sort of like you know the first 48 hours
after someone gets kidnapped also a
great show
yeah just get a lawyer you'll win good
uh when I watch it uh Tom segra has a
really funny bit about that by the way
but it is six months and he's at the six
month Mark he's coming up right here in
the six month Mark so if he hasn't
improved now now maybe it's just uh
again maybe it's an auditory processing
issue as he says maybe he's not able to
communicate the words but it's fine uh
in his mind he has full cognitive
abilities I genuinely don't know what I
do know is it doesn't matter because
like you said you need to be able to
communicate and articulate your thoughts
your job here is to be a conduit for
your constituents people who vote for
you that is your job you need to be it
is effectively to put a voice to the
people who vote for you and it's hard to
do if you can't speak without you know
[ __ ] your pants and forgetting where
you are I'll be fine
well the president has set a bad
precedence yes
precedence I think it's both
yeah it's both in that case so uh the
debate performance right they clearly
show that he's not able to do that and
by the way according to a neuroscientist
since I am not one says you know he may
never be do you get better
so it depends you know someone mentioned
therapy and therapy can be very very
helpful especially if you are doing it
every day and you're taking a lot of
time in your therapy essentially what we
know is that in the first three to six
months is where you see the most
Improvement there can be some
improvement over the next year but I
think he's about six months out now this
happened in May so I think if he was
doing therapy right after his stroke
this is probably where he's has improved
to the most and by the way I genuinely
hope I'm wrong I hope he recovers
entirely he just shouldn't be recovering
on the taxpayer dollar that's not an
appropriate place for you to be that's
what it is now of course people are
saying that this is ableism why because
they need to carry the water for uh for
uh not for fetterman sorry Federman not
Dr Oz it's tough because in a lot of
ways and they're of course using the
argument now it's just the new racism
it's ableism Prejudice towards
disabilities is what it is yes exactly
it couldn't be that hey maybe for
example if you don't don't have legs
it's difficult for you to run a marathon
that's not ableism it's a prerequisite
and by the way we have this all the time
we have qualifiers for jobs all of the
time if someone doesn't have a college
degree because they they didn't score
high enough uh on their SATs they didn't
get into the right is that ableism
there's always a barrier to entry and
this really does stem from a cultural
sort of poison of don't judge me so the
only God can judge me no no only God's
judgment is final only God's judgment is
what matters when it comes to the
ultimate truth you are judged each and
every day and you should be and you
should be judging others not judging
them as though you're a judge during
executioner determining whether they're
a good person or bad person but you
certainly need to be making judgments
when electing representatives that's why
we have elections but they want you
to feel guilty about that so here's
MSNBC columnist Liz plank she tweeted Dr
Oz just gave a master class on how to
bully people with disabilities by
talking and uh also when your side is so
bad you have to rely on ableism to win
here's another one journalist Mitra
Mitra Kalida tweeted it's fascinating
how stroke is wielded as a weapon in the
hashtag fetterman Oz debate literally
millions of us myself included who
identify as caregivers or survivors wait
wait how do you identify as a caregiver
you either are or you're not yes binary
as I was understanding it I didn't know
there's just someone sitting there with
an empty IV drip yeah identified as a
caregiver I didn't know how to do it
so I'm not a fan of Dr Oz just being a
doctor let alone in this but well yes
what's he doing he's talking yes that
doesn't what was he supposed to do mock
him and do an impression and of his
voice
simply to say this person may be unfit
so it finishes with this identity
someone who identifies as caregivers or
survivors Embrace imperfection and
Marvel at reinvention after stroke go
ahead reinvent yourself that's fine just
don't do it
on our time on the taxpayer Time same
thing in any sport yes I hope they
recover knee surgery you see this but
they can't do it if it causes their team
to lose and we have a segment we're
doing a change of mind on this on women
in combat roles in the military and the
police I'm against it women in combat
violent roles and enlisted Services
roles just to be clear it's a selfish
mindset of well if this person has
they're Reinventing themselves they're
breaking down barriers okay that would
be fine and you can make your own
decisions if it only affected you it
doesn't it affects the guy next to you
it affects your country it affects the
people electing you this idea that I can
choose to do whatever I want with my own
but sure you can and other people can
choose to judge you based on your
qualifications and judge you based on
your performance that's okay to do yeah
well and look you're looking at a
person's capacity to do a job and that
was the whole argument that we had
against Joe Biden is that it doesn't
seem like he's up to the task right he
doesn't seem like he's all there maybe
Joe Biden 10 years ago I disagree with
him still right but at least he was all
there at that point at least it appeared
that that was a the case with fetterman
I really do I'd ask a question to be
kind of funny earlier but when you're
debating somebody
would you have been any less prepared if
a guy had literally pooped and covered
himself in it and said fight me fight me
right I would have been like I don't
know how to respond to either one you
stole my story of the the guy on PCP I
did yes yes but that's the kind of thing
you're in a debate I saw it once
remember when uh Barack Obama
Barack Obama got his butt kicked in the
first debate and then the second debate
they're like oh you went a little too
hard after him you got to take Mitt
Romney back a little bit with Mitt
Romney yeah and he ended up not doing
very well in the second debate because
he pulled his punches if you're Dr Oz
there's nowhere to go here the guy just
answered incoherently he said good night
first you did I would have been like
well shoot I lost something what does he
what does he do when he reached to his
kids ah good morning Moon
good night Moon that jumped over the cow
what what huh
dad's going to read us an upside down
book again yes
he's reading backwards and his head's
spinning around oh it's Halloween it's
not any we've all had stroke victims in
our family and people that have had a
cognitive decline myself included as far
as that goes but that was self-induced
but honestly nobody wants anything bad
to happen to this guy medically no of
course not like that's what I don't
understand why you would call it ableist
it's like it's not anybody who is angry
or hateful towards a handicapped person
are the worst people on Earth and I've
only heard it like once in my life right
unless it's like a 400 pound lady in a
Hoveround who has a handicapped parking
well yeah then you tip her yes with a
group of friends yes you do oh yeah but
only
holding the security of the dark blanket
of night yes with no cameras yes I've
heard and then she jumped over the moon
so I doubt it here uh by the way so
that's now ableism ableism ableism but
again it's not even consistent it's just
the new racism it's a way to shut down
dialogue based on identity before you
get two ideas here's how you know
they're not consistent this was them
back then
do you remember
the media with Donald Trump where they
made it a big issue by the way and the
difference here is they were dishonestly
making it a big issue claiming he was
unfit for office here there are some
questions this morning about President
Trump's health and it's because of this
video of the president where you see him
walking very haltingly one leg at a time
it starts Happening Here people do tend
to walk one leg at a time that looks
like me walking on down Museum stairs
foreign
president Trump is not known for being
athletic
so maybe he just has a hard time going
down a gently sloping ramp
do you see something possibly
neurological that could be throwing off
his balance yeah by the way any of you
ever had a shoulder injury
is that what it was I don't know what it
was but the point is it was it was for a
very limited time and they made a big
deal about it it could have been you
know yesterday I had vertigo we talked
about that when I get head colds it's
just something that kind of runs in the
family that's different from someone who
has had a stroke and consistently across
the board is not performing to the level
that is required of his job and by the
way unlike fetterman with you know his
response is good night
uh Donald Trump had some great answers
to the media's uh questions claims
accusations sir
I'm ready General where we go
here we go now welcome
[Music]
I've got myself a problem General
because I'm wearing leather Bottom Shoes
which is good if you walk in on flat
surfaces it's not good for ramps it had
no handrail it was like an ice skating
rink I said General there's no way I can
make it down that ramp without falling
in my ass
jumping stamina or extraordinary if
elected Mr Trump against State
unequivocally equivocally will be the
healthiest individual ever elected to
the president
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I said doc I want to tell you I'll be
the healthiest president ever and he
said oh I think I agree and I think he
probably took my words he was the White
House stopped he was a great doctor you
know he was a Admiral a doctor and now
he's a congressman I said which is the
best have you had your choice
and he sort of indicated doctor because
he loved looking at my body it was so
strong
and by the way that's that's why I wear
these boots it's absolutely true it has
rubber it's a leather sole but it has
rubber there because this has happened
there are actually stories of UFC
fighters getting into street fights and
getting their clock cleaned because they
were in leather shoes if you've ever
worn leather shoes you know oh there's
no grip you just slip all over the place
so that's it was an easy answer but I
mean even if let's say that he was sick
and not able to get down the stairs very
well that wasn't a disqualifying
condition being able to move around and
run a race is not a qualification for
being president of the United States
being able to think kind of is is and
speak speaking is uh somewhat important
but you're ableist you're ableist that's
the issue here you're ableist when they
were making an issue that look can we I
think objectively we can all agree that
former uh former Vice President Joe
Biden is certainly less spry than
president Donald Trump and they this is
how the media says no no he's fine
they're being ableist they're trying to
use it as an attack than with Donald
Trump they would say well why is he
lifting this glass of water there's no
consistency and it's very clear that
it's just used as a tool these people
and when I say these people I mean
people in the media the entertainment
industrial complex they are so quick to
weaponize it when it's not significant
when it actually matters it's because
they are repelled by truth right Donald
Trump look for all of his faults he was
he had an incredible amount of energy
too much energy you can't say oh he's he
he's not fit and like he's tweeting too
much he doesn't sleep he just doesn't
stop he's fundamentally changing the
country yeah because he's enthusiastic
and he has energy yeah but they're they
are repelled by the truth and in this
case we know the guy had a stroke we
know that the six-month recovery point
is important and no no no no you're
ableist there really is a consistent
through line
if it's true they reject it and they
fabricate a lie and then they accuse you
of insert ISM here racism sexism uh
transphobic transphobism if that's a
term fat phobiaism I don't know I have
no idea and I don't know how you get
over fat phobia is it touch therapy like
when I was afraid of a spider I had to
hold it don't touch that that we saw
earlier you have to dance with it grab
her Rose
I meant with the spider yes well look
every media outlet that I've seen
covering this this morning has put like
a stroke survivor fetterman debate like
they're basically trying to carry his
water and lean into the fact that he had
a stroke so that they can say oh you
need to be sympathetic to him you're not
supposed to win public office on
sympathy it's supposed to be
qualifications any vote yeah exactly and
that's exactly what they're remember
when Mussolini won on his dyslexia right
that's true Joe Biden won on a stutter
so I guess it can work Pol Pot I have
ADHD oh well I mean Hitler won because
you could only grow facial hair right
yes
Charlie Chaplin very sad uh so this is
also they want to draw attention away
from the fact that when you do get down
to the substance uh look fetterman let's
get rid of it you can call me an ableist
races as well I don't care he lied so
either he is not mentally capable of
serving in office or he's a dishonest
person case in point he said he always
supported fracking is it a lie or is he
mentally unfit and he doesn't remember
you have to pick one I I've always
supported fracking I don't support
fracking at all and I never have um yeah
I called for a moratorium on frackings
there's no such thing as a green fracker
I'm not pro-fracking 2016 fracking
moratorium pledge that fetterman signed
for an environmental Watchdog group as
well as a 2016 tweet he sent while
running for U.S Senate I don't uh
support fracking I I think it's
something that has to eventually go away
and I would like to see it you know
transition out
foreign
you take your your pick by the way he
also released a 10 convicted first
degree murderers from prison what and
that's just a micro all the references
are available atoscatter.com as a mayor
uh he oversaw skyrocketing crime but of
course he's a Democrat so that's like
par for the course uh In fairness four
of those uh murders had Strokes yes ah
yes don't want to be okay we don't want
to be ableist well and only eight of
them are repeat offenders that's right
now so they've I mean you know it's it's
not as bad as it could be we need to
stop the overcrowding of our prison
system with stroke victims yes who do we
release first I don't know pick the
worst of the worst other than pedophiles
murderers it is yeah white collar crimes
no no no no no this guy killed a bunch
of people ah yes he has a droopy eye he
got it out of his system on your way
friend yes you're just misunderstanding
him
the the Braddock Town candle Face Killer
here's a wheelchair and a blanket
way good sir and a ballot and be sure to
vote yeah by the way uh this is a live
show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern and uh next week we have
something that will only go on Rumble so
you can watch us uh on YouTube on Rumble
there's audio Spotify Apple Android all
that and of course Mud Club we have a
whole additional segment on Andrew Tate
today another 45 minutes of show where
we'll get into theology a little bit so
nothing would make me happier than you
all switching and leaving to rumble and
next week we do have an interview with a
mortician an Undertaker who's had to
deal with bodies in the face of new
stuff medical advancements but that
won't be available on YouTube by the way
so I need that admonishment
I need it because I I talk to you and
you understand this need don't you yeah
you're right there and he wants one as
well if somebody's getting one he's
getting one when we talked about all of
the races that were closer than we
thought we actually left out a very key
race that most people aren't talking
about because it's New York assume that
a Democrat is going to be governor of
New York and uh it looks it's it's it's
within the margin I think with the
Quinnipiac poll um and also it's uh it's
almost too close to call in other polls
I'm a rasperson guy I just think that
it's fair New York we're sorry Trafalgar
you're doing pretty well as well please
elect somebody other than Satan that
turns out to be a woman month
you just brought it up to be admonished
yeah well I felt like I deserved it for
leaving out a very important detail so
good to get that little tingle down your
leg you feel good I did yeah you did
another one
give it to him
oh man here we go
why would I would do I'm just messing
with you so uh name that movie line all
right it's good Taylor Swift let's move
on to this now but we're talking about
ableism and you can't please everybody
because you say hey hold on I don't
think you should be a senator why uh
because you can't talk
ableist now let's go to another example
of how you can't please everybody Taylor
Swift of course as woke as uh as one can
get uh decided to release well first you
know what it's it's our entertainment
minute
[Music]
thank you
here we go hey remember when the Beatles
it was scandalous because they wanted to
hold hands with ladies I do okay just
take that keep it on the Shelf because
it will be relevant now Taylor Swift
just released a teaser for her new
upcoming video and she's in there you
would think appeasing the left because
she's getting it on her emotionally with
a trans dude
foreign
[Music]
we're a long way from teardrops of my
guitar aren't we
a lot of places to film yes yes it is
who is that a Lunesta commercial I think
so yeah
thank you
then they'll tell you about how
authentic they are so I'm sorry what
where was the trans person well here I
think we have an image right here
it's a Lunesta commercial it is so yeah
you wouldn't notice right not kidding
not a joke uh laith Ashley actually yeah
it's a is a love interest I guess that's
that's a that's a a trans woman whatever
uh What uh that use that he used to be
she no but I'm curious as to why we're
blurring nipples of a man uh because
solid solid transition yeah it's a solid
transition hey I mean if you're gonna do
it good for you good on you you know you
can thank your surgeons from the bottom
of your enlarged heart you gave 110 yes
and now you're in a video do you have an
idea how unnatural that would be in the
female body to get that to put on that
amount of muscle mass you have an idea
how much testosterone would have to be
coursing through that lady's veins and
so oh yeah there's a lot of quick to
anger moments yes
we're just supposed to okay okay what oh
nothing I don't want to be here I don't
want to get Benoit
yeah oh geez I see you're putting a
weight bench in the basement
what is this unbreakable geez okay
I think you should I think that warrants
a comment by the way comment below I
think look that is a pretty good that's
not a barely passable that's a passable
very not for the nipple bar five foot
four oh well that changes everything I I
don't know excuse me yeah actually I'm
taller than that yeah good for you I buy
four and a half we take five five and a
half thank you sorry so let's go let's
do it then and now here because of
course people have been upset with
Taylor Swift but back then and this is
how Taylor Swift became popular she was
an apolitical girl next door kind of
country music star right very talented
I'm not taking that away from Taylor
Swift was very talented for someone her
age when asked about politics back then
Taylor would give responses like I don't
talk about politics because it might
influence other people and I don't think
that I know enough yet in life to be
telling people who to vote for still
don't well no she's figured it out so
yes now
um she of course began showing support
for Democrats in the state of Tennessee
it was a huge story and of course
there's there are a bunch of other
agendas that she just she's decided to
to take on as her but I think we have a
clip the major term race in her home
state of Tennessee is a major battle
Swift had avoided politics in the past
but ABC's Eva Pilgrim is here with more
and Eva probably not a surprise to many
she's picking the Democrat in this race
but it is a surprise to say that she's
actually speaking about politics this is
so out of the norm for Taylor Swift who
until now has avoided any comment about
politics even taking out a post at one
point encouraging people to just get out
to vote but overnight the Superstar
making it clear to her 112 million
followers on Instagram and the world
where she stands
okay and then after the Roe v Wade
decision uh Swift retweeted Michelle
Obama and wrote I'm absolutely terrified
that this is where we are that after so
many decades of people fighting for
women's rights to their own bodies
today's decision has stripped us of that
I love how it's it's it really is with
the abortion issue and by the way they
have not been getting the traction they
thought they were going into the
midterms which I'm really happy about
it's just no no I don't have the right
to my own body if I can't abort a baby
again this idea that I have the right to
do whatever I and I know Libertarians
will maybe get upset with me here but we
did have a culture where you would take
into consideration how it affects other
people certainly if you're killing now
if you're terminating a life which we
know you are at the very least we can
agree in the third trimester at the very
least we can agree when it's viable even
if you're not pro-life you're certainly
terminating another life but when we
talk also about being a stroke victim
who's maybe mentally unfit being a
senator that affects other people when
we talk about women having to go into
the military in the Marines where they
can do half as many push-ups and still
get a perfect score that affects other
people it's not always about you if it
puts other people at risk if it hurts
other people it's no longer your
decision to make it's not at your
discretion that's the argument with
abortion is it a life that's the
argument we're talking about someone
serving in public office it's not that
we don't like them because he had a
stroke it's that we think he may not be
fit for the job it's not that you don't
have the right to your own body and so
you don't have the right to dismember
another body that's where the argument
is you may disagree but you need to be
honest about where the argument is and
if we can all agree that we need to get
to that point I'm not talking about
finding common ground I'm talking about
at least being honest in representing
your ideological and political
opposition you don't need to be nice you
don't need to find false Common Ground
you just need to be honest and I'm past
the point of believing that the left
thinks it's an honest argument to say
you're ableist thinks it's an honest
argument to say they want you to be
raped and they don't care about incest
it's not honest hit the like button if
you agree that helps with the algorithm
YouTube doesn't like it very much and
again no good deed goes unpunished
because I don't know if the control room
can bring up some of the uh the tweets
it's trending here this morning
uh Taylor Swift also pissed off fat
people
I knew that was gonna happen when I saw
his washboard abs yeah that'll do it
so there's big vagina pants yes
yes I've said it destigmatized
cap up here so you can pull him off I'm
not saying she's not adorable she does
have trouble keeping a man according to
her music yes she does yeah and by that
you mean any man yes she's gonna throw
some shade at John Mayer again who cares
so fat people are mad because in a Swift
video even though it's Pro trans and she
has a love interest who's a a man with a
I don't know I don't even know if he's I
don't even know if he has a John Thomas
I have no idea but she showed a scale in
her music video that reads fat
time everybody agrees
[Applause]
[Music]
so the idea there is supposed to be hey
you're being told that you're not good
enough right right it would seem as
though she's actually unfortunately part
of the pro-fat pride movement but they
were upset well it's self-depth it's
just it would not even sell deprecations
just it's showing depression it's
showing yeah can we bring that tweet up
again I don't know if you don't know if
you can read it says there is no
explanation for portraying fatness as
bad and as something to fear which
doesn't justify the hatred of fat people
oh really self-hatred isn't a reason
because that's what that's supposed to
be I know fearing fatness is a basic
tentative how about that phobia Opera
didn't lizzo have something with a scale
too was it in an actual video I think it
was where it said skinny and beautiful
Yakuza is that what skinny AF I think
skinny AF in her scale yeah so Taylor
Swift is fat and lizzo is skinny AF well
but if it's so bad why would it say
skinny AF wouldn't it just say fat
because that's what beautiful yeah this
is this is the thing where they want to
act like they don't this is the problem
with feminism okay it's the same
[ __ ] that you see in She-Hulk you
want to see everything that is wrong
with feminism try and stomach two
episodes of She-Hulk it's oh all guys
are completely incompetent when she
clearly is terrible at her job I can't
believe that people are mad at me for
being in this job but she was
unqualified for was given the job
because she's a celebrity superhero and
then at the same time I don't care what
anyone thinks about me while she's
getting custom designer suits and
dresses to try and look better it's the
same thing with lizzo I don't care what
y'all say I think I'm beautiful as she
signs a multi-million dollar Beauty deal
with makeup with perfume which by the
way you have to jump in a vat of that
because of the fat yeast infections the
point is they try and act as though they
don't care of course they care and this
is why there's no pleasing anybody
because it can't be objective truth if
you think that lizzo is skinny AF
and Taylor Swift is either fat or you
think that that commentary and that was
fat phobic then there is no truth that
can get through to you you're living a
lie also I don't know about you I don't
know about you
if you had your pick getting rid of
obviously like assuming like they
couldn't talk Taylor Swift or lizzo can
I just have the sandwich
what do you think it's prettier yeah
Taylor well yeah I gotta go Taylor I'm
being honest it's racism I do love well
no it's not it's fat phobia apparently
I'm afraid of fat people I think lizzo
would crush me and therefore I would die
so get your Little Orphan Annie LGBT he
fat Pride decoder pen yeah but she would
play a mean flute while I was dying yes
no but look I think Taylor Swift I love
it that they go after Taylor Swift I
love it that people who go out and try
to Virtue signal and say oh I can't
believe and say stupid stuff like that
we talked about with abortion what she
said about that you know it's our bodies
I can't believe we're losing our rights
I love it when the left eats their own
because it shows you that like you said
there is no pleasing them there is no
real Center to the left it is whatever
we think at any point in time and it can
be completely taken out of context do
you remember and this maybe wasn't do
you remember when she got in trouble for
having cornrows and eating watermelon in
one of her music videos I do is that
Taylor Swift that was they looked like
sugar Shawn O'Malley I think I'm 99 sure
it was Taylor Swift just hearing about
it
but it was just like don't get me
started on the video where she had
dreadlocks and was shaking her head like
corn Yeah well yeah that's true she had
a headache now she's not much of a
headbanger so she she absolutely got
roasted for doing that and I'm like what
what makes you stay on the left fear
like you have to because you're in the
entertainment industry you have to come
out and support these causes it's guilt
I'll tell you it's it's guilt here's
what it is usually you look at business
owners right and I mean people who are
wealthy because well because wealthy in
this country is you know 250 000 or more
is joint household income now it's 400
000 or more because
is anyone making more than 400 000
that's the ticket but the point is if
you look at most people who are wealthy
in this country they've had to create
businesses or they've had to provide
goods or services right they've had to
build it from the ground up and as
someone who's been in both sides who's
acted uh but who's also done you know
not only stand up but now employ 20
people I know what it takes to build
this up and it's hard-fought territory a
lot of people who are actors or in the
entertainment industry they're
incredibly talented
but they feel guilty because it's
god-given in other words they go from
nothing to millions of dollars and I
think they think there's a part of them
that says this easily could have been
somewhere somewhere someone else
somewhere else I didn't earn this
imposter syndrome right I think it's a
huge component of what happens I mean
you know this you know stand-up
comedians don't always have the most
amount of respect for actors who sit
there and [ __ ] about their craft and
how hard it is it's like you're saying
what they tell you to of course there
are great actors and they're fantastic
actors and they're terrible actors
but people who have to create something
and say well hold on a second you have a
script you have a producer you have a
makeup artist you have a stage and a
microphone yeah and people are going to
boo you if you're not good one try to
get you canceled and every other thing
yeah right but I think the real problem
with this too is
um Taylor Swift is putting out a music
video where she's trying to show at
least from what I can grasp from it that
people do deal with the fact that they
are say fat shamed or they do feel bad
about themselves or they do live in a
society where they don't feel like
they're good enough depression's at an
all-time high we give ssris to so many
people that you know work as well as Pez
you know and we we have a lot of people
that are struggling especially after the
pandemic with emotional disorders so
she's pointing that out but instead you
want to look look at it rifle through it
find the word fat not realize what the
actual meaning of it is and then poison
her with it right it just doesn't make
any sense to me it's like she's just
trying to point out how somebody else
might feel who's one of her fans right
but she has to like every other actor or
actress who has had this happen you have
to come out and fight it you have to say
agreed I do not care what you think
about this my point was this this is Art
trying to show you that people are
self-critical and don't shall have to
apologize for whatever for her obviously
she's not fat that's the whole point
right
yeah which one of those
right you remember Chris Pine when he
was listening to Guardians of the Galaxy
at the movie theater or watching it
responder Chris Pratt Pine the lesser of
the Chris's yeah um he's he said turn it
up and he tweeted it out turn it up
hashtag Guardians of the Galaxy or
whatever it was and the deaf Community
came after him I'm not even kidding we
covered it on the show no I remember
right and he he came out and he actually
signed an apology and I was like
you just you just have to say I'm sorry
you can't hear it this music's amazing
he didn't have to at all deaf people no
yeah
that is true he he really didn't need to
Target now the deaf Community is a big
thing you know uh reg obviously worked
here is brilliant he he has a son who's
deaf and another one who is hearing
impaired and he said it's really a
problem that doesn't need to exist in
modern times in the sense that you know
you either get to the point of Cochlear
implants or right you know hearing aids
have gotten much better for sure not
entirely solvable but we've made great
strides and there's an entire component
of the deaf Community who says well no
that's shaming deafness and they want to
remain deaf go watch the sound of metal
I watch this is great acting like wait
he gets kicked out of the death the deaf
Club because he got because he got a
cochlear implant you kick him out oh
he's no longer one of us yeah it's like
Children of the Corn why not yes was
that children of the corner freaks bro
yeah
my point is this lizzo you're not
skating as F or aaf skinny AF I don't
care let's move on to school this is
what actually matters hopefully we can
Safeguard against this this ABS
tomfoolery I'm trying to We Can't yes
that we can't All Is Lost it's like that
Robert Redford filmed
that was a terrible movie boy it left me
wanting to kill myself he made he's made
a lot of kind of back before being
honest yeah yeah speaking of crap let's
move on to public schools here so in
this country right now you may not know
of this and I think this is really
valuable because for the first time we
kind of have an Apples to Apples
comparison which we didn't have before
with homeschooling and with public
schools because the methods were so
different right yeah and now a lot of
homeschooling has moved online and of
course we know for the last two years
Public Schools who have a way way way
more money and qualifications have
largely moved online as well well the
2022 results from the national
assessment of Education sorry National
assessment of Education progress the
naep it's the acronym isn't even short
enough
so grades four through eight they're in
we have an assessment now
it's not good new test results from the
nation's report card show in Most states
fourth and 8th graders are falling
behind in reading and math lesson scores
are historic the worst decline ever
recorded with roughly 25 percent of
fourth graders and 38 percent of 8th
graders performing below the basic level
the lowest of the three achievement
levels for the test students who are
already struggling in school showed the
most dramatic drop-off Secretary of
Education Miguel Cardona calling the
results appalling and unacceptable is
that that guy that makes like 450 000 a
year uh I think he makes a lot of money
did we talk about that guy these results
are appalling and unacceptable well
who's in charge here
president against me yeah that's uh it's
my fault I did a really bad job what are
you gonna do about it well not much you
can't fire me no don't be absurd I
wouldn't fire myself don't be uh don't
be
meritocritist I've got tenure yes I need
a raise yep so ACT scores by the way
also uh for uh the 10th through 12th
grade have fallen to their lowest point
more than 30 years the lowest since
1991 and by the way this is even for
states that don't administer
standardized tests California for
example their proficiency is down across
the board right only 47 percent met the
standard for English only 33 with the
standard for meth that's a four and six
and a half percent drop since 2018-19
right that semester in both categories
that is dramatic
and that's also I think putting children
in public schools today is is tantamount
to child abuse hit the like button or
you can comment below if you agree but
here's the thing with all of this
happening with people having the lowest
test scores with people doing very very
poorly in school and not being educated
they want more money yes when they go to
the workforce yes because they don't
have enough they don't have enough
skills right to earn more they have
degrees and they have all the money but
they can't out compete mom with an iMac
and by the way though we do need to be
clear right both sides of the coin here
not all people were negatively affected
uh by the pandemic in the online
learning challenges for example here
we've lived this right we've hired uh
some great new interns
[Music]
hey dude what's the craziest thing you
did during your online learning I
cheated on my Spanish final nice
um
I eat I use my brother's old pieces on
stingrays to pass biology yeah
I had had sex with my teacher
weren't you homeschooled
yeah
[Music]
won't you come to me
[Music]
so
I have a question for you
the result
the results for public schools are in so
let's connect can we compare it to
homeschooling and by the way the more
you dive into these numbers all
references are available at lottery.com
we like to think that all homeschool
kids they're they're maladjusted and
that's bad they don't do very well and
there's been there's been a real
Movement by the way not just people like
John Oliver but people in the government
from the left trying to make it more
difficult or nearly impossible to
homeschool in Canada where I was raised
I knew one kid who was homeschooled I
don't know the regulations and I know
it's a lot of Hoops to jump through and
you made fun of him most likely yeah
well he was weird Simon was a weird kid
According To You Porn it's a sticky
situation it can be so here's uh the
United States census their pulse survey
showed homeschooling skyrocketed from
five percent of households in the spring
of 2022 to over 11 by the Fall so a
doubling to be clear and we have the
results again they're learning online
right in public schools a lot of
homeschooling now is online or at the
least at the very least parents are sort
of following along usually mom big
components with a syllabus I don't know
if you call an online syllabus exactly
or some kind of a course outline
homeschool students on average scored 15
to 30 percent above public school
students in the standardized academic
achievement test and here's something
else that's important black homeschooled
students black American homeschool
students actually did 23 to 42 percent
better than black students in public
schools and this is data you won't have
but I'm willing to bet why
or at least it's component probably uh
young black Americans who are being
homeschooled I'm willing to bet that a
higher percent of them have fathers in
the household because of the kinds of
people who typically homeschool they're
typically traditional you typically need
a father there if you're going to have
one of the parents homeschooling a
strong family unit because it's even
more drastic than just the average it's
higher for black homeschool students so
for talking about this we're talking
about improving we're talking about
improving the black community here in
this country why don't we talk about
homeschooling because it's not a money
issue yeah well I think there's a large
amount of peer pressure as well that
that they're benefiting from at home
school yeah yeah depending on the
neighborhood yeah well I mean it's one
of those you made the point like you
obviously you've got to have somebody
earning living somebody's staying home
with the children right do the
homeschooling but I I don't know if I
had to guess my impression of
homeschooled people like you said
maladjusted like socially a little bit
awkward I would not have guessed doing
much much better overall than public
schools oh I did I never would have
guessed that really no I I know some
smart people that were homeschooled but
I would just assume that the school
system would have you know billions and
billions of dollars to have better
Educational Services for people and I
was wrong no no no I wasn't I would
never have guessed that I just I know
are you serious I never would have
guessed that you never would have
guessed that homeschool students do
better than public schools too no I
would have thought that they just chart
their own curriculum well I mean I was
like Mom can't possibly be as good as a
public they still have to get their GED
no I do they well Oh you mean the
homeschool yeah yeah no I understand I
thought you meant what I mean yeah sorry
they're good enough to agree yes
so no I I'm surprised that you're
surprised yeah no I I always said I've
always known that the numbers are higher
but here's where it also is is even more
important when you look at how much
money is spent on public schools you
know you see those stupid bumper
stickers when the Air Force needs to
host a bake sale to raise money for
their bombers and public schools get all
the money they need if you look at total
spending when you include federal and
state spending we spend way more on
education now let's also look at
specifically right you would think the
pandemic
people now could say well we weren't
prepared the reason it's gone down is
because we weren't prepared for the pet
by the way the pandemic did not cause uh
proficiency scores deployment it was the
insane dishonest reactions yes to covet
19. covid-19 didn't make kids Dumber
also you weren't prepared well 190
billion dollars that was allocated to
schools in response to covet says you
were
190 billion dollars and you're acting
like it just came upon you like a thief
in the night 190 billion should soften
that Landing a little bit because that's
what you guys said you needed you said
teachers unions across the country one
you said you couldn't go to work because
it was a scary place because people
could get sick right even though we knew
a lot about the virus by that point you
just said we need more money they were
striking in Chicago for more money yeah
they were striking everywhere that they
were striking for more money because
it's all about the student it's not
about the teacher but but if you pay me
more I'll do a better job that's
essentially what we've been hearing but
then we give you 190 billion dollars in
additional funding that's either
earmarked or taken already right and
your results well the average standing
spending per pupil um or the federal
government I believe I believe this is
only a federal government we have the
references uh yeah only the federal
government That's not including State
spending which is a huge component of
public schools spending thirteen
thousand dollars per student by the way
in some low income districts the coveted
funding alone and by the way when I say
low income I do mean there's a higher
percentage right this is where they'll
try and accuse you being racist if you
say there's a higher percentage of black
Americans but then they'll say by the
way uh of course uh there's
environmental racism because these uh
these factories or these uh these oil
refineries they get set up in low-income
low-income areas which have a lot of
black people but if you say it here look
this negatively affects black Americans
more so in some low-income districts
coveted funding alone allocated an
additional thirty thousand dollars per
student wow and homeschooled kids
children do we say of color that's the
term it feels dirty saying that I'm
gonna say black kids
person of color is any different from
colored people and I just feel like five
years from now it's going to turn on us
so black is always relatively safe there
you go thirty thousand dollars per
student now let's compare that to so
that's 190 billion just covet
okay now there are 3.7 million
homeschooled students right as of 20 20
21. that actually saved taxpayers 56
billion dollars you know you've heard me
talk about this when people say well the
wall is going to be expensive the wall
if you were to build it on the southern
border would be somewhere between 20
billion dollars to 40 billion dollars
depending on the estimates you use
illegal immigrants cost the taxpayers
well over a hundred billion dollars
annually right homeschooled students
save 56 billion dollars for taxpayers
190 billion net negative right you spend
it versus making 56 billion hey we also
know the test scores are better we also
know that it helps students of color
more how about we create this is a
perfect example we don't need to spend
more money we need to pull it back and
create incentives and make it easier and
more efficient for kids to be
homeschooled and let them maybe
participate in sports there maybe
participate in some of the
extracurricular activities make it more
of a part of our society because we know
that it performs better but it's the
money that's the money principles I mean
the reason they have attendance policies
it's not because of the test scores of
course they have to have a baseline but
when they go way below the Baseline and
hit their head on the bar they still get
to do their job right it's because the
more days you're there that's how they
get their money and their funding if
you're not there they don't get paid for
you that day from the government that's
how it works there are taxpayers out
there just waiting to give you their
money
are you man enough to take it do you
have the balls to take it it takes brass
balls to be a public school teacher I'm
sorry real hero
I'm here on a Mission of Mercy
I wish when I was getting screamed at
for never going to class they were just
like it's about money yes yeah they
would have that's exactly what they
would have just said it they should have
been like look oh okay 20 bucks a class
yes yeah make a deal we've known this
before but I'm hoping you know I talked
about this yesterday you know you see
Cuban Americans are the most
consistently conservative voting Bloc
why because they've lived it because a
lot of Cuban Americans they're actual
refugees by the way they were a
generation of refugees right so they
fled a government which was legitimately
persecuting them okay to be clear and so
since they've lived it they have said we
reject socialism in all of its forms and
they're reliably conservative we've
always known that spending does not
correlate with Public Schools no uh to
any type of actual measurable outcomes
by the way for example there's no
correlation between spending and better
scores Washington DC they spend thirty
thousand dollars per student on average
it's the second worst okay in the
country as far as the naep wonderful
acronym who's number one I really want
to know is it Detroit first I have no
idea I thought I thought Detroit would
be in the running it could be
Poughkeepsie just be one
yeah didn't Ellen give the school board
of Detroit like a giant check and then
they just went and bought stuff for the
principal
several times everybody who has a lot of
money thinks oh I can just throw money
at it Mark Zuckerberg gave a hundred
million dollars or at least contributed
to the fund that raised 100 million
dollars for Newark Public Schools when
Cory Booker was there and actually
running the program I've mentioned it
before it doesn't do anything so it does
not do anything it went to him getting
some wonderful haikus for his Instagram
well yeah oh my gosh that guy's just the
worst Tatum no here's but now you're
living it hey parents you're what I'd
love to hear from you below right now if
you're watching if you're listening have
you had kids in public schools or if you
homeschool has it really been affected
by the pandemic do we also really want
an education system that is beholden
beholden to a a bad flu
four kids when we're talking about the
death rates for children
no this is the issue we've always known
that spending does not correlate with
better outcomes and now hopefully you've
said oh 190 billion dollars more money
than ever going into public schools are
they better objectively they're not
subjectively do you feel better about
sending your kid to public schools so
don't ever let the left say oh we're the
empathetics you're not empathetic what I
don't want to spend money in the
military I want to help our kids look
that would work if the premise was
correct that throwing more money at the
education system makes it better it
hasn't now I'm not saying that throwing
more money at it makes it worse but I
can say that there is a reverse
correlation if you actually look on a
graph the more money we spend the
proficiency scores have gone down so I
can we can all definitively say more
money more money more money is not the
solution and we can all definitively say
that homeschooling produces better
outcomes and saves the taxpayer money
people want to talk about non-partisan
issues oh you're just shouting over each
other okay
where's the Common Ground here I can't
imagine an issue where we should be able
to find more common ground maybe Charter
Schools but you guys don't want that
it's really bad we talked about this
before we locked down the schools and
the teachers didn't want to go back to
school we had doctors saying that not
only are going to have mental health
issues the likes of which we have never
seen but this directly affects students
and their ability to learn
you made your decisions yeah well and
one of the things that we didn't talk
about but if you look at Catholic
private schools yes in that same
proficiency report that came out and he
made Catholic private schools a state
right they would be number one in every
category for proficiency number one one
of the differences with Catholic private
schools one so this is the same solution
with the ruler and make you drink uh
thank you last night's vomit they beat
you and then they sprinkle you so that's
fine walking bull-legged yes no but the
the two things and you can take these
over and you can apply these to public
school as well one is parents are paying
to send their kids yeah the private
school so parents are invested there's
buy-in in their education right and two
better quality teachers because there's
competition at private Catholic schools
if you don't have a good Academic
Program which means you're sending
people to the next level either for jobs
or to colleges they're doing well
they're having good outcomes people tend
to look at your program and go ah it's
not worth the money I'm gonna go do
something else public school has never
had to compete right all you need to do
right now is get rid of funding for
public education get get rid of all of
the payments certainly on the federal
level yeah for the federal level get rid
of all the payment mechanisms whether it
be property taxes in the state of Texas
or other places that tax another way
give that money to parents and say okay
here you are responsible for your
child's education because guess what you
are it doesn't matter what the
government does you are responsible for
your child's education and teachers
you're going to have to compete just
like everybody else public school was a
great try yeah we missed it we need to
change and we won't unless teaching
unions are gone you know what it makes
me think of too people would always say
you know they talk about Ebenezer
Scrooge by the way but it's my favorite
piece of fiction ever is A Christmas
Carol it's like the Fifth Gospel yeah
but A Christmas Carol evanese it really
is a story of a liberal becoming a
conservative because remember when they
came to him for donations he said oh
there are no prisons are there no poor
houses these are government-run entities
in other words in his mind it was that's
off my plate right I don't need to do
anything about it the government's
supposed to handle it is it and then
after his moment of redemption he said
you know what it is up to me to get to
charity it is up to me to be a good
Christian to do the Christian thing to
help my fellow man it is not up to me to
just pass it off to the government and
of course this is also I see the left
that they want to remove the tax exam
status of the church this is why the
left constantly denigrates the church
constantly misrepresents the fact that
they're more giving that they're more
charitable they're more generous middle
class Christian conservative Americans
are the most generous people on the
planet as a percentage of their income
Bar None it's not even close references
available at laddercutter.com we've
talked about this several times before
it's really easy for the left to say
we're compassionate especially when 47
of Americans don't even pay any federal
income tax maybe it's down to 43 right
now I don't know really easy to say yeah
yeah that's being taken care of over
there I've done my part it's a lot more
difficult for you to sit down and look
the people who are affected in the face
and do your job to help them and you
know what your job is in this case your
mom your dad
you need to teach your kids you don't
need a degree
you just need to care
but of course we know all the true
heroes that's you know that's their
problems they care too much that's true
they give too much and by the way I care
too much about quality Firearms so
before we leave uh Walter they're the
official firearm of Lottery Studios uh
this is the Walther PDP you can go to
waltherarms.com shop online or they'll
find your dealer locator look I don't
need to say this is like cheat codes the
PDP with a red dot it's absurd just go
and try it they have the balls to
sponsor the show I think you'll love it
and uh you know look everybody out there
if you're a parent you put your kids in
public schools oh well I have no Common
Ground With You YouTube we're about to
talk Andrew Tate
is off
[Music]